موضوع كبير موضوع البطاقات الائتمانيه
كلنا عنا بطاقات ائتمانيه واعتقد اغلبنا
مش عارفين كيف نستعملها بالطريقه المسلى
وشو كيف تصرفنا ايضا في حال انه تعرضنا
للسرقه
من حساب البطاقه الائتمانيه شو بنقدر نعمل
في هاي الحاله من حالات تعرض للسرقه
البطاقات الائتمانيه حالات دوريه تحصل
ممكن كل ساعه
فالبنوك عندها طرق اجرائيه سريعه جدا في
الحالات هذه فعاده عند سرقه البطاقه او
الشك في السرقه هناك طرق لازم الشخص
يتبعها اول طريقه وقف البطاقه عن طريق
مكالمه البنك عندهم خط ساخن او عن طريق
الابليكيشن مغلب البنوك عندها فيك توقف
البطاقه رح يقدر يسترجع الفلوس اللي سرقت
في حال لاسترجاع الفلوس هناك اجراءات
ثانيه تاخذها البنك وكذلك الشخص يتم اول
شيء مثلا المفروض الشخص ساكن في الامارات
مثلا وما سافر لبلد معين ويلاقون انه
هالعمليات شراء تمت من بلد معين فيعرفوا
انه اكيد هي عمليه احتيال كذلك لا تنسي ان
هناك ناس كثير بتحاول تحتال على البنوك
كذلك فالبنك لازم يتاكد من من عمليه طيب
خليني اسالك عن
الرقم السري اربع ارقام يكفون ولا لا
والله لو كانوا حتى 20 رقم ممكن ما يكفي
لو لو تم الاحتيال بتطبيق رقم معين يعني
لا اربع على سته ولا عشرين طيب اليوم حتى
احنا لما نستخدم البطاقه الائتماليه ونذهب
ما في ثلاث ارقام سي سي بي 3 ارقام هذه هي
اللي من الممكن يتحصل اي مكان او اي محل
تجاري على الرقم وعلى اسمي ومن ثم هذه
الثلاث ارقام ويقدر يستخدم البطاقه
الائتمانيه هل هو تناقض في في هذا النظام
ولا ايش حقيقه ممكن ناس كثيره تسال انه هل
الكرت تبعي يكون مخزن عادي عند اي محل
عاده هذا الموضوع لا يمكن لانه عمليه
البيع تكون عن طريق زي ما انت شايف اللي
تكون عند صاحب المحل تكون من بنك معروف
فهو على طول يكون مخزن حتى المكان اللي
انت تشترين منه ما انت بعض الاماكن يطلبوا
منك البطاقه نفسها الرقم برقم البطاقه
والاسم والثلاث ارقام بالخلف هذه كل
معلومات البطاقه بالطبع هذه هي هنا
الكارثه استخدام البطاقه في مواقع غير
معروفه هنا هنا الموضوع لازم يكون عنده
حملات توعويه كبيره لازم الانسان يفهم وين
يقدر يستخدم بطاقته يعني مواقع معروفه
اللي هي الناس كلها تعرفها محميه لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات